help us change the culture by buying our
latest single from tim cast records only
ever wanted by clicking the link in the
description below
here's the first story
the reason this story is important
because um gavin mcinnis may have been
arrested we don't know the daily dot who
um likely just hates gavin writes was
proud boys founder gavin mcinnes
actually arrested following his live
stream well i believe it's betridge's
law is that it you want someone affect
you man this one has never heard of
headlines if a headline asks a question
the answer is no that's correct yeah i
have heard that is it better i don't
know if you're looking for what we got
so much fast typing in this yeah come on
guys better law of headlines
i can't believe i remembered that
properly i'm always mixing it up it's
better so uh here's what here's what
happens there's this video of gavin he's
doing his show i think we can play this
named after ian betterage hey really an
ian a british technology technology
journalist so here's here's gavin
mcinnis we're shooting a show can we do
this another time
then he gets up and he like doesn't say
anything for a little while
and then it's really quiet because he's
away from the mic
he says uh let's see when's he gonna say
it i think we gotta jump in sit down and
have a conversation we'll schedule a
meeting
and we'll sit down with my lawyer yeah
he says we'll schedule a meeting we'll
sit down with my lawyer now i'll say
this
a lot of people are like it's got to be
the feds because um i think it was will
carlos this journalist called the local
police and they're like we did not
arrest them and there's been no
announcements by law enforcement or
anything about a possible arrest
who knows what's happening is he in the
u.s or canada he's in new york this is
the kind of thing where you
law enforcement i believe they would
make a big headline out of this i don't
think so gavin no that's a privacy
violation i'm pretty sure they wouldn't
just arbitrarily announce we have
arrested this man but with trump they
were like we have went into mar-a-lago
wasn't that a big deal he was the one
who yes
and and with roger stone they tipped off
cnn so it depends on what the police
government wants to happen i don't think
this because gavin is a master troll
like the proud boys is a master troll he
did he set that com that cup that group
up as a troll and
but i don't want to like talk to say
that if he actually got arrested because
that's you know i don't i don't i don't
i don't care who you are
i'm even even the boy who cried wolf in
a circumstance like this i'm not going
to start by assuming you fat you faked
some kind of arrest or something and you
got you got to understand too in this
clip
he didn't even say he was getting
arrested he just left the show in the
middle of the show for all we know
when he was pulling into his driveway he
scratched his neighbor he bumped his
neighbor's car and they called the cops
and he's doing a show and the cop shows
up and then they said like you hit that
car you got to come out and he's like
i'll get a life like it could have been
something as innocuous as that and then
they were like no you're coming out now
and then the show goes off the air
because he's outside and he's like
arguing with people and exchanging
information and they're yelling at him
who knows did they leave the show
running after that yeah they're running
so josh denney who is associated with
gavin mcinnis and censored tv says just
got off the phone with our people it's
not a bit gavin was against going to
january 6. he was against
charlottesville and told proud boys they
were out of the club if they went but
he's rotting away in jail because he
dared to question authority oh wow you
know i kind of feel like it's hard to
believe what do you think
i
don't
think it's hard to believe that gavin is
against january 6 no no no no publicized
i think getting arrested i know he's
against january 6th because he's i
i'm where to comment on this
there's a part of the video where he
says uh i didn't let you in here and i
don't know a ton about gavin studio but
that i think that's significant that
either means that they
um felt like they had
reason to entry a reason to enter and i
assume that means they were serving an
arrest warrant it's hard not to see it
that way
um i don't think
that
you know he's been silent ever since so
that's also significant i think his fan
or his i think his company or he would
address it in some way if everything
were fine if that makes sense i think
the fact that we are not hearing
anything
the longer it goes on becomes
increasingly more suspicious
will carless said trying to confirm
what's up with gavin mcinnis abruptly
leaving his show last night in the
middle of his live stream a colleague of
his tweeted mckinnis was hauled off by
the feds but no charges filed on pacer
or press releases from doj fbi no so
reserving judgment fair point fair point
i don't know
i don't know
because you know ian you mentioned he's
a master troll he certainly is but i
will say
scott adams
remember what he tweeted july 1st
2020. yeah i do i remember it
he said republicans will be hunted
everyone made fun of him and then it was
two months later that aaron danielson
took two to the chest from uh from a
black lives matter activist with a blm
tattoo on his neck
someone was just insinuating that mega
republicans were dangerous
mega republicans but it was like they
specified this mac these maga who was
that it was on twitter i think it was
today even was it a problem republicans
it was biden wasn't it yeah
i don't know
have you guys seen the trailer older man
who keeps just rambling i don't know
have you guys seen the trailer for my
son hunter oh gosh no not trailer i just
thought it exists i saw the trailer
it looks really good gina chrono's in it
oh cool but my only con my only my only
issue with it is that it makes joe biden
look very strong
incorrect inaccurate yeah because like
he's like there's like a scene where he
confronts hunter and he's like what did
you do and then i'm like joe
he'd be going like come on man
crack pipe
porn pop what are you doing to me man
unless unless the angle they're going
with is that it's an all it's all an act
so that his enemies think he's a
fumbling bumbling you know look people
people are like i'll put it this way
conservatives are acting like joe
biden's not really the one making all
these moves so he's sort of getting the
blame deflected off of himself by by
being this way so imagine
he's actually totally lucid and strong
and he's like listen here listen to your
champ i just made a bunch of moves guy
look fat i'm the one taking the economy
but i'm not gonna take the blame for it
watch how i pull this one off what
economy
that's the thing
ronald reagan apparently when he was
leaving office he had also apparently
had alzheimer's that's the story but
some people think that he had been
embroiled in some corruption and it was
coming out and then he started saying
like i can't remember i don't remember i
don't remember and his memory started to
fail him all of a sudden and then he was
off the hook yeah they're going to be
like they're going to so the republicans
are going to win they're going to file
investigations
in november and then they're going to
subpoena joe biden and he's going to be
like
uh i did what and you're going to be
like mr president you had a conversation
with the president of ukraine about a
billion-dollar loan guarantee
a billion-dollar bone guarantee wha
who
there were all these stories about like
this is starting to seem like elder
abuse like i think everyone was saying
like he's just he seems so out of it
that it it's almost cruel to force him
to do this i don't necessarily agree but
like in some ways i wondered if that
story was to set him up for like
sympathy from the american public should
anyone ever try to prosecute him in the
future because it's like look he wasn't
he wasn't well then and he's not he's
even worse now like we we always just
give him the excuse that he's like old
and decrepit even though he was
this way when we elected him maybe maybe
he is
being
controlled by somebody else and he's
just a puppet maybe he's secretly strong
either way you've got a conspiracy
theory on your hands but this is what i
want to get to if this gavin mcginnis
things turns out to not be a hoax and he
was actually detained for some reason
then uh
the fact that information's been
withheld and that he he would be in jail
is actually really really terrifying
which is why it's like it'd be really
awful if it was a stunt or some kind of
prank or something he might come back
and be like i didn't prank anybody you
know i got into an argument with a
neighbor and then we canceled the show
and then everyone started claiming i was
arrested like what happened you know
ferrari could be like that
but considering that the the president
just got his home his house rated and
and the reasoning behind it seems to be
completely
like fraudulent and corrupt in my
opinion
these are these are scary days you know
like i mentioned scott adams said
republicans will be hunted he did say
you'll be dead by this time next year
yeah or something like that
but a couple months later dude was shot
and killed with just being a trump
supporter so it's like
it was right for somebody and if you
mean it in like the unpersonal way like
if you ban people from platforms that
are mainstream and you cut them off from
society you're not literally dead but
you are uh
your influence is over if that makes
sense that's that's what i think more
people
the attempt is with most people who have
like mega ideology they don't want them
to have any sort of influence over
politics so if they can shuffle them as
far into the dark parts of the internet
as they can and be like oh they're
extremists you know that's the that's
the ideal scenario so let's let's um
let me let me start by saying
i'm looking i'm really excited for
november
you know people pointed out that new
york 19 was supposed to go republican
but it stayed democrat so that's a bad
sign but then someone else pointed out
that democrats won that district by 12
points they just won it again by two
which suggests a major swing in favor of
republicans so i just want to make sure
everybody's got that little optimism in
their minds and i will also add too on
the culture front we released a song
it's got 480 000 hits probably like more
than that with across the platforms so
like things are going really well like
i'm actually i'm feeling pretty good
daily wire is hiring disney cmo like the
market you know like
i think we're doing really well and
every day
the the the cult
seems to just falter and and fail and
stumble that being said
in their desperation
you will see the death throws and the
death rattles
so
going after donald trump's home rating
it
gavin mcginnis maybe being rated or
arrested i don't know desperation yeah
but desperation uh project veritas
getting raided and now we got the story
in the new york times about these people
selling the diary actually bites diary
to james and it sounds like they're
going to try and go after veritas
we may be winning but of course no one
in the culture war is going to just give
up right yeah so if freedom liberty
moderation libertarianism conservative
values american values all of these
things which don't completely agree with
each other but have this coalition start
winning are we about to see a dramatic
escalation in corrupt law enforcement
and political you know
authoritarianism well surely they're
going to be held accountable after the
next couple months and they can't allow
that
i mean when a cornered animal lashes out
you know in its last desperate move
that's when
the republicans have the advantage of
typically they
are the party of inaction i would say
and in this case inaction is probably
the best thing to do really they're
being provoked into do something make a
mistake but actually just by sitting and
waiting until november that's probably
the best move for most of the center and
the right go tell all your family
members to vote and go vote yourself
replace all the jerks
and then hopefully the rep the
representatives who are elected are
going to be able to clean up instead of
trying to
uh seize the ring of power for
themselves and then the corruption
spreads but it comes from the right now
i gotta give
i gotta give an amazing white pill
moment for everybody i was laughing with
such a joy earlier today
so i tweeted out that youtube changed
their rules right
i did this big long thing because
youtube removed the rules saying you you
can't claim that that masks cause lung
cancer and that masks uh uh
you know a whole bunch of claims the
most absurd of which was that
youtube now allows people to claim that
masks cause lung cancer which is weird
it's insane yeah and so i did this big
thing of all the rules right but one of
them was about the efficacy of the
vaccines and marjorie taylor green
tweeted me and said so in other words
allowing some truth
some truth something like that she was
not endorsing any of this stuff a bunch
of outlets wrote articles claiming
marjorie taylor green endorsed his idea
that masks caused lung cancer and then i
just busted out laughing
she certainly did not
she was making a comment about reduction
in censorship some of which these things
are actually asserted by the cdc she did
not say masks do this it's like saying
there's some good people in the united
states and people doing like you think
murderers are good people exactly what's
that joke of i i like pancakes yeah are
you saying you hate waffles yes yes so i
i just laughed i'm like this is all they
have
this is what the media has now they're
so desperate so they're front they're
they're scraping at the bottom of the
barrel so hard they've started pulling
up wood chips yeah and the timing is
right after she's been swatted what
twice so they're like no sympathy points
for her she thinks like masks give make
you have lung cancer stay away from
archer taylor green like it's so
desperate what they're doing there's
another fake meme where they're like
marjorie taylor green was talking about
solar energy and claimed that you would
lose electricity at night and she said i
don't know about you but i like having
the lights on at night
and then all these leftists are mocking
her and i'm like
are you are you joking she's right solar
panels don't work at night and so the
issue is with with solar power as a grid
feature is that you need massive
batteries better better technology that
we don't actually have and so that's why
solar works great supplemented by
natural gas
was that her point because that's
actually correct but they snip out one
weird sounding thing
anyway the reason i bring that up as a
white pill thing
when we're talking about winning in
november g prime you know he just
mentioned george she said get your
family go vote you know marjorie attends
everybody you know everybody you know
when marjorie taylor green
is is winning and she's like raising
more money than anybody else and then we
see a whole bunch of maga republicans
that they hate so much winning carrie
lake sweeping every district in arizona
arizona has been slowly turning blue
because of california people fleeing
california kerry lake still swept every
district is that border yo the border
i'm saying
after everything i've seen this year
trump's endorsement record is like 99
success crazy
i'm ready to order a bunch of nachos sit
back grab some beers and be like this is
good news everybody some organic just
make sure make sure you don't you don't
just rest on on these victories you have
to make sure now
you know when the enemy the center has
has crumpled you don't just go okay it
crumpled we can chill no no no now you
take the hilltop so come november
everybody you got to get everybody you
know
and then finally
if we can get enough of these actual
american value politicians in maybe get
some accountability and some investments
a good point if you truly if you really
win which it feels like sometimes i feel
like i am winning in life like this is a
this is a victory so then it's your turn
to build you now have the land the land
is yours now you must create something
sustainable so that you can you and your
friends can stay you and your people
your your brethren it's really red
team's game to lose
in sports terms it's sort of like um
conservatives in general strategically
are hold your ground and play defense
it's hard to go on offense with your
shield up you're stepping forward
stepping forward holding your ground but
now it's time to you have the ball go
towards the end zone
i guess my problem is that i worry that
i mean we grew up we're all about the
age where we remember when the
republicans pushed a little too hard in
the early 2000s and stuff we've seen
them
go on offense and then make so many
mistakes that they make themselves look
foolish and then they get replaced by
the left because the left says we want
change from these bad policies these i
always talk about the patriarch and all
that stuff i hate that stuff and the and
pushing wars and let's go invade
everybody it's like no how about we just
focus on america for a little while and
that's what this new form of
red team is doing i want to see what
happens when they have control of the
ball
um i i don't we've never seen what
happens before have we i don't think we
have well how do you see america fitting
in with a new world order
uh it depends who's in control of
america right i mean if
if in the next two and a half years
brian's still in control of the
executive branch let's say or his
handlers are still in control
uh legislative might lean red uh supreme
court's leaning red now so i'm guessing
it's going to be lame duckish for the
next couple of years maybe policy wise
as far as the new world order is
concerned uh they might just be planning
to do things without america's
involvement
would be my guess because america is
kind of crippled as if we have
a blue executive branch who won't
pass any of the legislation that they
write
on
red team let's say we want to pass these
bills and job buttons like no i'm just
not going to pass it not going to pass
it so then it goes to the supreme court
and then we have more fighting on that
front but as far as what they're trying
to push like what
i mean what new thing is going to happen
next two years that the uh liberal world
order or whatever the world economic
forum what are they going to try to push
in the next couple of years aside from
cryptocurrency as the new digital
currency like dispensing of the dollar
erosion of human rights in general
we'll just i guess we will be watching
helplessly as the rest of the world
loses their rights and then hoping that
we're one of the last countries that can
at least openly criticize this stuff
yeah whenever there's a revolution ah
honestly i don't think there's ever been
a revolution i was reading about this
where the the bottom tier of society
rose up and took the top it's always
that
a top and a bottom aspect of society are
replaced by a smaller top and bottom
segment of society so
and it's so it's like you can't well
that that maybe is a little different
than the point of that you can't really
revolt a system doesn't revolt alone
it's with because of outside forces like
the french won the american revolution
yeah that'll be very strange if let's
say there's um
uprisings throughout the america i was
talking about these yesterday i think
they might try to import uh like private
military from other countries to try to
be peacekeepers or something that would
be absolutely horrifying or maybe we
were talking about this offline with
those stupid uh boston dynamics robots
patrolling down the street
trying to hold the hold the piece in
like new york state or something if
there's like weirdos in the woods trying
to hold their ground i guess are there
peaceful revolutions in history like are
there you guys know of any i can't name
one off top of my head i guess he's full
um
there there are a couple examples i
can't i can't remember what's up my head
though
throughout the bankers like in 2008 they
were like we're done with central banks
we're taking control of our money didn't
didn't canada just be like hey we're
gonna go our own way oh and they were
like okay canada
something like that i don't know there
have been but they're extremely rare
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there